you're being honored tonight you brought
out some serious fashion for the night
what inspired this look
um well Vivian Westwood has always been
one of my favorites and uh it's baby
blue and uh Pink which is trans colors
so I thought I'd represent and uh yeah
it just felt like this today so any any
secrets to this look any secrets to this
look uh these shoes are really hard to
walk in
um and yeah that's about it and these
are sticking together and I can't use my
phone with them
together
ET has stuck with you for a long time
and we are so happy
big things were in your future you were
like dreaming of of one day you know
playing big Arenas and having
chart-topping singles and now your
Grammy Award winner Kim Petras
a life change
so much it's incredible how kind of
quick it happened because I've been
doing this for years and I've known you
for years now and it's just been so
amazing and it's just this big reminder
to keep going and keep believing in
yourself and uh I'm so lucky that I have
the fans that I have that are so loyal
and sticking with me thank you guys I
wouldn't be here without you and I die
for you guys and uh yeah just you know
keeping yourself and do what you love
and uh because that's kind of how the
song happened we just both love the song
and we're just you know no matter what
happens we're both really proud of this
and then everything else happens so it's
incredible the first time you and I
chatted you told me Madonna was one of
your Idols you dreamed of one day
working with her fast forward she's now
calling you a friend and you're with her
you know what I mean I saw you guys
partying at the Grammys together what
kind of friend is she what is it like to
say you're friends with Madonna I mean
I'm such a huge fan I mean I I don't
know how good of a friend I can be to
her because I'm just like confessions I
changed my life you know every time I
see her I just talk about her music and
what it means to me so but uh it's just
been the most incredible thing for me to
uh get you know respected by Madonna and
for her to even know anything about me
thank you so much it is okay so now that
you're friends are you wrangling her to
be on the album I I would die too yeah I
would die to have Madonna on anything or
be on anything Madonna so uh yeah
absolutely tour album this year uh
definitely tour an album this year yeah
really both yeah and if you can describe
this era of Kim in three words oh
um it's just completely new it's a new
side of myself and uh I've got some
really sick features that I can't talk
about but uh yeah it's me to like the
maximum of like why I make music
[Music]
thank you